Many times when you look at a very successful
business from the outside, it looks like everything's
going perfect.
Like there should be zero problems.
But, in order for a company to become successful,
they've got to do the ugly things very good,
behind closed doors that nobody sees, and
one of the ugliest things you'll ever have
to do, as a leader, as a boss, as a CEO, as
a C-type executive, whoever it is that's running
the department, is firing people.
And today I'm going to talk to you about how
to fire a teammate, someone, or an employee,
part of your company.
And before I get into anything I'm going to
cover here with you, I want you to keep a
couple of things in mind.
You've got to follow your state, and your
country's human resources, HR guidelines.
So whatever I tell you, your laws go first.
These are just simple philosophies on things
that can help with your business.
Look, I've been around the block for a while.
I've hired and fired so many different people,
and the first time's always a difficult one.
It's very similar to, the closest correlation
I can give you on what it is to fire somebody
is when you're breaking up with somebody.
It's always good if somebody has broken up
with someone and someone else has broken up
with you.
If you have experience on both sides, you
will know when somebody broke up with you,
it hurt.
And you will know when you broke up with somebody,
what their reaction was.
And there really is a general consensus to
how things should be, the goal is you want
to finish things amicably, right?
So, you know the typical breakup - what's
the famous breakup line?
We all know it.
Honey, it's really not you, it's me.
I'm the problem.
We hear something that says, I just don't
see this thing going the direction we want
it to go.
Hey, we both knew this day was coming, or
whatever it is.
We have all these breakup lines.
Firing has also got some lines, but I think
it's very important to know you're dealing
with a human being and if the first thing
you think about is you're dealing with a human
being, you'll take the approach in a completely
different way then looking at someone as let
me just fire this person because it's robotic.
You're still dealing with a human being.
So 11 points I'll cover with you that will
help you out.
Before I get into that as well, one of the
biggest reasons why you have to put yourself
in the position to fire somebody is because
you didn't properly hire somebody.
So what do I mean you didn't properly hire
somebody?
Why don't we talk about that first?
So Pat, what do you mean we didn't hire someone
properly?
Did you call references?
What type of references did you call when
you spoke to them?
Did they go and talk to some other people
to see if their personality is going to fit
the culture?
Did you just hire them because you liked them
a lot, but they have zero skill set?
Did you do a background check on them to see
about anything that they have going on?
Did you ask the proper question when they
say, "Oh, I've taken a sabbatical for two
years and I haven't worked."
Is that really the case or is that a script
some people say when for the last two years
they have had a job, but they didn't finish
well and didn't want you to call the job because
you don't want the reference.
Maybe they didn't quit the job.
Maybe they were fired.
Maybe they have some bad things they don't
want to tell you about.
Anytime somebody's got a long gap in work,
there's a concern.
There's a red flag.
So you've got to ask those types of questions.
And once you ask those types of questions,
then you hire.
Sometimes you also try to force someone's
talent into a job that they're not a part
of.
I'll cover that as well.
You've got to figure out who the person is,
do they fit the position, then you hire them.
So, above anything, the rule that I live by
when it comes to hiring and firing is hire
very slow, fire extremely fast.
Hire very slow, fire extremely fast.
There's nothing worse than a boyfriend and
a girlfriend being in a relationship that
they know is never, ever going to work out,
but they just keep dragging it out and it
just keeps wasting both of the people's lives.
I've done it, many people do it, there's no
need for it, when it comes to business.
So let's get into the 11 different points
that I have.
#1: First things first when it comes time
to fire somebody.
The goal is to fire them gently.
Period.
What does this mean, fire them gently?
They didn't work out, they leave, you're happy,
they're happy, no more I can't believe this
is what happened, I can't believe that is
what happened - your goal is to fire gently.
There doesn't need to be any kind of retaliation
on both sides because the employer can obviously
hurt the employee, and the employee can obviously
hurt the employer.
So if anybody starts it, both ways it's not
going to be pretty, and it's not going to
help the career.
Why is it not going to help the career?
Because if the employer bashes the employee,
that means new employees don't want to work
for the employer.
Because everybody that works for this company
if you leave, they're going to bash you.
And the employee doesn't want to bash the
employer because no matter what other place
you go to, one of the worst things I like
to hear in an interview is what?
When somebody is sitting there and I'm interviewing
them, and the employee keeps bashing the prior
two companies they worked for.
The companies are not the problem.
Generally, it's the person who's the problem.
It's not necessarily always the company.
So if the person says, "Oh, my last boss was
this.
My last boss was this" - we already see a
sign of that.
So as somebody that's hired a lot of people,
that's a red flag, when I'm looking at hiring
somebody.
So the goal is to let people go gently.
Look, I have a daughter.
One day, my daughter's going to date a man.
And they're going to go on their first date,
and she's going to have a boyfriend, okay?
Now my daughter right now is four months old,
so that's not coming for at least forty more
years, right?
She's going to take her time for going and
having a boyfriend.
But when that day comes, and she has a boyfriend,
and then there's a breakup, as a father, and
my personality is extremely over protective
and I have access to the resources, to money,
I know people from all over the place, there's
a lot of different resources that I have access
to.
My goal is for that breakup to be what?
To be as amicable as possible, and for the
boyfriend to not go bashing and saying things,
and my daughter to not do either.
None of them.
Hey, if it didn't work out, it didn't work
out, you guys go your separate ways.
That's your outcome, with 99.9% of the people
you fire, that's your outcome.
Now, what's the .1%?
The .1%, this person breached the contract
and they want to go out there and do something
that's going to hurt the company?
Well, it's unfortunate, but this is what general
counsel and legal counsel comes in, and I
won't get into it.
I've been on both sides of the aisle myself.
I know exactly what it is to be on both sides,
so I know the experiences, but that's the
.1%.
And when the .1% takes place, you've got to
make sure you do something that will protect
your company that you worked very hard for,
if somebody decides to go that route.
But that rarely happens, very, very rarely
does that ever happen.
Point #2 - when you're firing somebody, get
to the point.
Don't drag it out.
There's nothing more annoying than a drag
out breakup.
Hey, this is not working out, here's why.
I want to get right into it, I don't like
firing anybody, this is the part of the business
I don't like, but this is just not working
out.
[snap], to the point, okay?
And as you're going through it, there may
be a part, a shock factor to the person, [Mario,
I'm not pointing at you because we're firing
you, I'm just looking at you here.
. . ] there's a shock factor to somebody you
fire.
So, you know the shock factor is oh my gosh,
what do you mean?
So there may be the opportunity for them to
say, "But I thought this.
I thought it was working out.
I thought this."
You don't need to defend yourself because
if you're firing somebody, when it gets to
that point, you have already done your proper
homework.
Especially after watching this video, where
you're not firing because you're winging it.
You're firing because there's a lot of other
things you're going to do before you fire
somebody.
So you need to stay firm.
#3: The next point is stay firm, as you're
firing somebody.
So gently, get to the point, stay firm.
Don't defend why you're firing.
Don't defend, you know, constantly with them
going back and forth.
This is not a debate.
This is a decision.
We're not debating here.
This is the decision that's been made, you're
fired.
You need to move on, and this just didn't
work out.
Gentle, clear, to the point, firm.
#4: and then after that part, acknowledge
their feelings.
Listen, I understand that this may be a bit
of a frustrating moment for you.
I understand this may be a disappointing moment
for you.
I've been fired before and I can tell you,
it's not very exciting when this happens.
However, I just want to make sure I totally
understand your feelings and what you're thinking
about.
#5: Next, typically, the protocol I like to
follow is, exit interview is always done by
the person who hired them.
If I hired Mario, I'm firing Mario.
You don't give your dirty work to somebody
else.
If you hired somebody, and you were the person
that said, We have made a decision to give
you the position, you need to make sure you're
doing the firing.
Now let's just say if you did the hiring,
but they worked under John, who runs that
entire department, then it's you and John
together in the room, talking to the person
that's getting fired.
Both people.
But there needs to be an exit interview.
Sometimes people do firing in ways that just,
you know you just got to do it and take care
of it and this is not a way to hurt somebody.
You want to make sure it's done in a proper
way.
If you're dealing with somebody who's a vendor
or somebody who is an independent contractor,
that's helping you out with your IT services
and you're firing them, obviously, you're
going to fire them over the phone, or something
like that.
But if you're dealing with somebody that's
in house team, you're doing it face-to-face.
#6: Generally, it also shouldn't be a surprise.
This is point #6.
It shouldn't be a surprise.
Let me explain what I mean by that.
Generally it shouldn't be a surprise, and
here's why it shouldn't be a surprise.
It shouldn't be a surprise because throughout
the process, let's just say if Bob has worked
with me for 60 days.
And within the first week, two weeks, three
weeks, four weeks, I will generally know areas
that I'm not happy with Bob.
And I'll say, "Bob, this is very important,
and this was part of your, what we hired,
when we hired you, on the application, it
explained your job description.
I want to highlight, this is part of your
job description.
So I'm going back to the job description that
I put up - important - if you don't have a
clear job description up front, then they
can come back and say, "Well, you never told
me this was part of my job description."
So they're held accountable to what?
Their job description.
You can tell the job description here and
you're not doing this right.
You told me you type 65 words per minute,
but it looks like you're typing 35 words per
minute.
You told me your spelling is right, but there's
seven, eight different spelling errors here
in this email you're sending to a customer.
What happened here?
Tell me about it.
Do you really know?
Okay, here's what I want you to do.
Why don't you write this out, or whatever,
you're doing some testing, you're doing some
accountability and coaching, right?
So if it happens again, another time, and
you say, "Bob, this really needs to improve.
If it doesn't, it's part of your job description.
If it happens again.
. ." or "Bob, you told me you're somebody
that shows up on time, three times in the
last two weeks, you've been late.
"But it's only eight minutes."
Eight minutes is eight minutes.
Eight minutes is a long time, but you're still
late three times in the last two weeks, and
you said you're punctual and we're expecting
people that are here punctual.
I just want you to know, if that continues,
that's going to be a challenge.
So let's just say those two things continue,
right?
When it comes down to firing them, they're
not sitting there surprised, because you're
going to say, Bob, I don't think this is going
to be a surprise to you, because you know,
when you got started, you were late three
times in two weeks, and I told you that's
an issue.
And this has happened again three more times
in the last four weeks, so we just have to
let you go.
Boom, to the point.
See how easy that was?
You're getting to the point.
Hey, look, one of the job descriptions, and
I brought this up to you several times was
you need to be working faster.
You told me you work in a very pressured type
situation, but it seems like a couple times
when it was you hitting deadlines, you didn't
perform well during deadlines, and this happened
on three different occasions.
And that's very important to us.
And we just have to let you know, we have
to let you go.
And I'm sure it's not a surprise, because
this has been brought up.
So if you do it properly, while you're going
through the probationary period and you're
telling them areas they need to improve in,
there's not going to be a surprise when it
happens.
And many times, they'll even know that it's
getting to a point that this may not work
out, and many times they'll quit before you're
going to fire them.
It's the same thing.
If you do it proper with accountability, it
will get to the point where they'll say, "You
know what?
Honestly, I just don't think I fit.
I'm just really trying and really doing this,
it's just not going to work for me."
No problem.
I totally understand.
Boom.
All good, we let you go.
It's a lot easier.
Sometimes you want the other person to break
up with you, right, because you don't want
to break their heart.
And sometimes when the other girl or guy comes
and says, I just can't see this going long,
and in the back of your mind you're saying,
thank God she just said it.
You're right, I wish it would, but you're
right.
Let's just move on.
I agree.
So that happens as well.
So that happens as well, many times when you're
going through that.
So that area's covered.
. . okay, perfect.
#7: So next one.
The next one is as you're doing the exit interview,
here's what I like to ask.
I used to, thirteen years ago, get right into
giving feedback on why I'm firing.
Some people don't want it.
And they're offended.
Now, I ask.
Do I have your permission to give you some
feedback?
This is the exit interview.
Would you like some feedback?
Yes, I would like to get some feedback from
you.
When you are giving feedback, I cover feedback
in a couple of different ways.
And my feedback is extremely intentional because
I have one outcome with me letting you go.
My goal is for you to leave me and do 10 times
better than you did while you were with me.
That's my goal.
When I let an employee go and it didn't work
out, I want you to go be successful.
I want you to go out there and make money.
I don't want you to stay on unemployment.
I want you to go figure out a way to make
money.
So I'll say, "Look, there's a couple things
I want you to know about.
One of the things I want you to know about
is it just seems like you're always late.
Second thing I want you to know about is it
seems that you don't follow details, and details
is not your game.
The third thing is your customer service needs
some work, the way you talk to people.
If you're planning on being in a part of business
where you're touching the customer, that's
got to improve.
So you may need to be the a behind the scenes
type of a person, that you're not touching
the customer.
That's okay.
They don't need to see you.
But if you're going to be touching customers,
that's got to improve.
Or it could be another thing where, look,
if you don't know something, don't tell people
you know it.
Three times you told me you know it and you
didn't it know it, and you lost credibility
with me.
In the future, I'm a lot more comfortable
with the person telling me, Patrick, I honestly
don't know, but can you give me a date to
learn it by?
I like that response.
Why don't you use that response in your next
company?
That's a great idea, and they'll take notes.
Perfect.
Any questions you have for me?
Boom.
But you're giving feedback there.
And you talk about their strengths, because
there isn't anybody you'll ever find that
does not have strengths.
So when you say that you can't really think
of anything positive to say about the person
- everybody, everybody I've ever fired, they've
always had strengths.
It just didn't work out for many different
reasons.
So you do want to highlight their strengths
that they have as well.
I remember one time I had an employee.
This was what year, Mario?
'05, '06.
I might give this person a nickname.
The right people know his nickname.
His nickname is Hoot.
And he loves the fact that I'm mentioning
his name in this video.
I won't give his full name.
First of all, I loved this guy.
He is probably one of my, if not my favorite
assistant of all time, who at the same time
was by far probably the worst assistant in
the history of assistants.
This guy was terrible.
He was horrible.
And I dragged it out for eight months.
I think it's more because I loved him, he's
like my younger brother.
And he was terrible at it!
I mean, things would never get done.
He was never organized.
I was telling him what to do every single
day, instead of the relationship being the
other way around.
But he liked to, you know, be around my cars,
we'd hang out, he would listen to this stuff,
we would drive in the cars, we'd go places
together so it was always good.
He was very good at making sure the oil change
was done properly.
He was very, very good in that part of it.
And one day I sat him down and I said, "Hoot,
I've got to tell you this, man," and he knew
it was coming.
"Hoot, buddy, I've got good news and I've
got bad news.
What do you want to know?"
He said, "Pat, I know what it is, but tell
me the bad news."
The bad news is you are terrible.
My gosh, you are terrible at being an assistant.
He said, "What's the good news?"
I said, "You have no idea how much I trust
you.
I trust you.
You are such a kind human being.
People love being around you.
But you're not a good assistant.
And I will tell you this.
Sometimes, people who don't make good assistants,
they make very good entrepreneurs.
They make very good independent contractors.
They make very good in a completely different
area.
So this is not a bad thing.
But what do you want to do with your life?
And we went through a conversation together.
I said, "Listen, tell me what you want to
do with your life?"
He said, "Pat, honestly, I love surfing."
I said, "Okay, so what's your point with surfing?
Many people love surfing."
He said, "No.
I REALLY love surfing."
I said, "Okay, tell me what you really love
about surfing" and he went into it.
I said, "So why don't you go travel the world
and go surf all the places you want to surf?
You're 21 years old."
He said, "You think I can really do that?"
I said, "Yeah, go work all over the place,
and go surf.
What places do you want to surf?"
I want to surf in this place, I want to surf
in New Zealand, I want to surf in Australia.
I want to surf in.
. . He went through all these places in the
world he wants to surf.
Do you know what he did for the next 10 years?
He went and surfed at all these places!
He literally lives there.
He lived in all of these places.
China, some strange places in the world, and
he went surfing.
And you know how he made his money?
He made his money teaching other people how
to surf at the beach, while he was surfing.
So while he was teaching other people how
to surf, and working at restaurants, he was
surfing.
And he got that out of his system.
But I'm so happy for him because he was able
to go and pursue what he wanted to do with
his life.
He was a terrible assistant.
Till today, very good relationship, he comes
and sees me or my kids, he can spend the night
at our house, he's like family to me.
And he's probably watching this right now,
cracking up, and he'll be one of the first
to comment on this.
Hoot, much love to you.
Much, much love to you from me and everybody
else to you.
#8:Don't drag it out.
Do not drag out firing somebody.
If you're going to fire somebody, and you
already know that they need to be fired, don't
wait two more months.
Don't wait four more months.
It's probably not going to change.
Things that are very, very important for that
job to be done, it's probably not going to
change.
You need to fire them.
You need to fire them now is what you need
to do, if there are things that you don't
necessarily see improving a lot.
But some of you are going to watch this and
you're going to say, "I have to go fire these
three people!"
Wait.
Have you given them already the feedback on
those areas you need to improve, and have
you given them two, four, six weeks to see
if there's going to be progress on it.
If you have gone through all of these, then
fire them.
Don't get off this video and just say I'm
going to be on this firing one, I'm going
to fire every single person I see in my office.
Then you'll have nobody left and you'll go
out of business.
You don't want to do that.
But once you realize who it is, you've got
to make sure you don't drag this entire process
out.
#9: I already told you kind of earlier, hire
slow, fire fast.
#10: Always when you hire people, have a 120
day probationary period, sometimes 90 days,
sometimes 120 days, which means you're getting
an opportunity to work with us for 90 days
. We will decide within the next 90 days if
you'll stay with us, but this is a probationary
period.
At any point we could decide to go a different
direction.
Are you comfortable with that?
Yes.
Perfect.
Come on board.
And we give them their 90 days.
Your 90 days is going to be August 1st.
Your 90 days is going to be July 1st.
We just want you to know that during these
90 days we're going to learn a lot about each
other.
Are you comfortable with that?
Yes.
Perfect.
So then, while you're firing, you've got to
also be prepared to have a plan for replacement.
You need to replace this person that is no
longer with you.
So there needs to be a plan of replacement.
Sometimes you can do it properly, with that
person that's going to be leaving trains the
replacement.
They train the replacement.
And there's nothing like that if you do it
properly.
Train the replacement.
We just had to do that recently ourselves,
and there was a process of training the replacement.
If there isn't a training for the replacement,
you're going to be out with somebody that
needs to know what they're doing for that
two to four-week period, and you don't want
to be doing that, right?
Or if it's somebody that you just hired and
it's only been a month, you can fire them
because they can't train the next person anyway,
right?
So it's very, very important, very, very important
for you to know also that you have a replacement
in mind.
So, with that being said, this is probably
not the most exciting subject, but many of
you keep asking me about how I fire people,
and how you can go out there and fire someone
properly, as an employee or team member.
This is how I've done it over the years and
it's gotten better and better over the years.
It becomes very clear once you have a philosophy
in place of how you do it.
It becomes very easy.
But the key is, when you're building a team,
if you don't build a team full of talented
people, you're constantly going to be firing
a lot of people if they don't really know
what they're doing.
Hire properly and you won't have to fire too
often because it's never pretty.
It's very annoying.
So with that being said, Mario, where's my
favorite pillow, buddy?
Let's send that over here, okay.
We now have a goal [somebody catch it], we
now have a goal.
I normally say 100,000 subs, but now we're
trying to get to a quarter million subs by
when?
June 1st of 2017.
I know it's a long ways from now, but we've
done the math, June 1st, and we're totally
okay with hitting it sooner.
We believe we're going to hit it sooner, but
our goal is to get to a quarter million subs.
Be sure to click on the button and subscribe.
[Easier catch.
You're just sitting there.
Just a simple catch.
It's called a good quarterback threw it to
you, instead of throwing it all the way on
the bottom here.
Pat Brady, that's why Mario didn't play American
football.
He confuses them sometimes, because he plays
soccer.
He's actually pretty good at playing soccer.
One time I took Mario to a soccer league and
it was a bunch of nice people.
Mario ends up tackling the main guy who was
a senior pastor of this entire organization
and he gets up, looks at him when he's on
the ground, and talks smack to him.
And then they said, "Why did you bring this
guy?"
I said, "Man, he's competitive.
What can I do about that?"
So anyways, subscribe.
If you've got any questions or comments about
this, comment on the bottom, if you've got
questions about the subject.
With that being said, thanks for watching
everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.